look at you [ __ ] [ __ ] hey what's going
on everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings and today I'm joined by Joe Budden
he's a headline factory right now Joe
welcome to the show thank you for having
how are you with hot food horrible
horrible with hot food yep you're about
to have a horrible time there's still
the whole I am black and this is chicken
so you're gonna get through summers do
you think you'll get through all of it
we've had five people not make it
through for the fun DJ Khaled didn't
make it through no way Tony Yayo didn't
make it through Mike Epps didn't make it
through Jim Gaffigan didn't make it
through Rob Corddry didn't make it
through we can add me to that list
shortly
this first one is sriracha now that I'm
good how many people made it this far
every single person you knew we're gonna
talk about drink so I want to start with
Drake right off the bat and this thing
is becoming such a complicated thing I
feel like you could host a three-day
symposium and not get to the bottom of
it so let me just tell you how I see it
you can tell me what I'm missing okay so
from what I understand you feel like you
took some shots here at 4:00 p.m. in
Calabasas right I got people showing how
much they truly resent me
they hold of me and it just spells envy
they shot at him and you're a fan of
Drake's music thought you feel like he's
become kind of content with success
would that be a fair way to more or less
put this in a package no how would you
describe it then I would describe it as
I'm an MC and anybody who puts my name
in a rant or mentions my likeness in a
rap can expect bars and you said it's
kind of interesting that like you know
somebody gives me two or four bars I've
given him 75 back from a different era
from an era where that was that's what
we did that was like by default in north
what's changed
oh please come on you work in hip hop
I'm gonna explain it to you everything
sir there's like certain people who are
gonna say Joe's doing this to troll a
response like Joe's doing this to draw
attention what do you say to those
people I don't do anything for attention
I haven't done anything for attention in
my entire career anybody who's followed
me knows I've done [ __ ] pretty much the
opposite I've done everything to not get
attention even with all these interviews
I ain't Dunham I'm kind of shocked at me
and you were doing why cuz I just don't
remember that part about the eating
chicken but we're here and I love you
with conversation so I'm all for it but
not oh I don't want to talk about any
other man but me unless they address me
in a bar but Tapatio is a household name
have you ever heard a type of tea oh yes
I have dated enough Spanish woman to
have her there
few people ride as hard for Jersey as
you do and it's really refreshing to see
because like we just talked about
hip hop's changed quite a bit and part
of that is the regionalism of the sound
completely gone you know everybody kind
of sounds the same or like takes from
whatever is popping on the internet but
you really ride hard for Jersey which is
something that I respect and want to
play a game called how Jersey are you
have some Jersey quickfire questions I
just want to know what you think sound
good most here what's your exit state my
[ __ ] edge there's one camera Jesus
Mary and Joseph already got [ __ ] [ __ ]
is wrong no Jesus Mary Anne shoe maybe
where your favorite restaurant is you
gotta have a favorite exit I do have a
favorite exit but just think I died
telling it to the [ __ ] public alright
fine means that we have to lie to you
and I don't practice living that way for
this and I don't want you to lie to me
I don't do that what's the best jersey
diner can you tell me that one I hate
diner yeah what even though Jersey is
like diner
capital of the world but if I have to go
to a diner depending on what time it is
because not all of them with 24 hours of
litical chest what are you gonna order
Oh Who am I with you and me oh I don't
know
Bryce neighbor some [ __ ] Taylor ham or
pork roll will never call that a port
room you would say Taylor ham 100%
greatest Jersey MC not counting yourself
I wouldn't save me anyway who would you
have said Oh Treach Redman and Lauren
good enough for me weirdest fact you
know about Jersey Jersey City is eight
miles long there you go so I don't know
any of what you said I don't know how it
matches up against Jersey will let the
Jersey viewers decide okay I already
know I'm Jersey
what is this [ __ ] on milk is on the
melt of Jesus Mary chosen man anybody
hood in here can [ __ ] real can't even
feel like a man
Jesus is the big secret of shows like
Love & Hip Hop is that the real drama
happens between shoots with no wouldn't
know only remember doing love me about
yes you do
well you remember doing Chengdu I don't
never happen in my brain it was that bad
experience no I love all the experiences
but just where I am today I get to pick
and choose what my brain wants to
remember I learned at a therapy so I
don't have to remember any i Function
people sometimes subconsciously suppress
memories that are difficult to deal with
but you'd have to learn how to suppress
it is that what you're saying that you
can kind of shut off that part you can
learn yes can you give me a quick lesson
don't worry too much go away why not why
would you share the wisdom of each oh
all wings matter got to get to the next
one this guy see him this Vince Vaughn
looking guy here nothing about what he's
experiencing looks pleasurable so why
would I do it because for the people Joe
because I want attention alright let's
do it let's talk about these goofball
kids that were hanging out outside your
crib over the weekend it's difficult to
put together the sequence of events
because at one point you're in your car
at one point you're outside at one point
you're both in cars 7:30 in the morning
I went and walked to my vehicle not
worried about what I was wearing at the
time and I wasn't very coherent cuz I'm
not normally coherent without my morning
coffee my morning cup of joe look what I
did do right so I get my [ __ ] car and
[ __ ] I looked at her laughing his two
kids outside of my door with a [ __ ]
camera net now that's not enough to get
me out of character give me out of my
vehicle but then they stayed and they
started chanting some [ __ ] I think it
was Drake lyrics okay their car said
[ __ ] yo get your kill one of you [ __ ]
but I realized they were children so you
know that's the end of that you run them
off and then that's that I couldn't got
my coffee I came back they spent the
entire day it wouldn't got their friends
I don't know maybe was a pokeymon spot
or some [ __ ]
happened when you open the door the
first time because the snapchat cuts out
nobody on what they kept doing was they
kept parking three houses now so I
didn't know that I was just chasing I
chased them in when I realized they were
kids I stopped and I saw I'm getting a
car and they drove off I thought that
would be the end of that and then they
continued to do that for the rest of the
day and because I'm super petty in my
head and had absolutely nothing better
to do on a Sunday I said and because I'm
a little off sometimes I said I'm gonna
catch one of [ __ ] and I'm gonna bring
him in here and I'm a beat they [ __ ]
ass right I said wait a minute Rick Ross
did something like that and he got a lot
of trouble big headache I said look slow
down then I said wait a minute
good go out there with my gun just shoot
somebody now a real man that damn sure
nope nope won't join me nope nope and I
thought a big shot in the air it could
have all been bad cuz I'm a little off
so when you filter your craziness you
come up with let me chase the kids with
rocks and give them a stern warning oh
I'm gonna kill what him those means were
hilari us yes and you said some of the
funniest names I want to show you some
of the memes that popped up and I want
you to say that you know the ones that
you like the ones that you don't like I
just weren't sure of it all right laptop
please but this is kind of fun now it is
yeah once we stop talking about [ __ ]
drinking it's wonderful
alright cuz then he's just gonna [ __ ]
be on me again and said you know I will
never give you a boost I am too smart
and I'm gonna say stop typing words like
boost to me you see this one the GTA one
that was a popular thing this one was
real good I enjoyed this one a lot the
GTA thing yes cuz he did kind of look
almost exactly like the guy that looks
great and whoever did this did an
amazing job do you see this one they did
the Olympic one mm-hm too easy too
obvious yes not no creativity involved
it's just a bad job it's doesn't look
good
can I show you one more it's one that
complex made and and I you know what I
like about you you shoot from the hip
you're real honest so if you think that
this is lame let me know if it's lame
okay if you like it let me know if you
like it let's do it alright I love this
one it was
yes terminator I told in this morning
that this was my second-favorite
shut up yes for real this was my second
favorite one and I don't even [ __ ] with
char like that I know I know that's not
very happy to get you here no this was
my second favorite one only behind the
dude oh he reenacted the whole thing and
it was really a Joe Budden look-alike Oh
the parody was great that was my
favorite and this was my second favorite
this one is a hot one hot ones and
you're on the hot one shows how this is
our hot sauce I see what you did there
just one good thank you job the hip-hop
ads would kill me if I didn't ask you
about slaughterhouse no that wouldn't be
the first time that hip-hop has appealed
somebody that makes me feel zero
compassion for whatever you're asking
you're not gonna let me out there yo
it's my birthday me the picture who are
you and why should I care about your
birthday well I'll tell you why a
chicken should care about slaughter
Houston seems to be an interesting time
Royce is sober Joell Ortiz I see him in
the gym it seems like maybe we're
gearing up for something right what's
next with slaughterhouse oh no not any
idea I know Royce is moving around I'm
moving around crook and Joella moving
around we all have spoken and we don't
think that we have a time where we gonna
get together and make something happen
that's good slow stalks are still
happening in the soy sauces it's family
that's only on to create the [ __ ]
stories everything be perfectly fine and
tools of [ __ ] tweet pills that
somebody with Wi-Fi and just a nose what
I broke up and then complex and all the
rest you've got Alan's fine everything's
fine well then that's why we just have
to have you Joe just regularly coming in
here eating wings with me setting the
record straight I will always come in
here and eat wait if we can get some
sides next time
this one looks a little so damaged we
can always you this is a switch
situation if we roars don't look the
greatest I'm alright you're taking deep
breath and [ __ ] all of epic I know I
know what to expect I know what I'm
going through it'll be a man I'll
remember you shut up look at you Wow
[ __ ]
alright so I need some strip club advice
for you because you kind of have it down
to a science so let me tell you I'm
retired from going to strip club well
since they did I haven't go on a strip
club in quite some time a lot of false
allegations come from strip clubs
I have nothing no reason to be in a
strip club but but lately give you
advice up from some of my past that's
what I want to know all right let's do
it so let me give you my plan of attack
and you tell me in which way I'm [ __ ]
up okay and I don't have rapper money so
try not to laugh am i overhead here so
here's the situation probably between
300 450 bucks cash right and my whole
thing with strip clubs is there it's a
lot like playing golf or something I
have fun for the first hour and then
after the first hour it is impossible to
deal with I'll go in there and I'm a
real quick fast spender so I'll get a
lot of singles and I'm just throwing
those things out I'm very liberal with
the singles always throwing those things
out can i interject with questions as
you go throughout the story him yeah
let's go why don't you just go in and
have dialogue with the woman you've been
intimate with the ring because I've
never I've never walked in there and
somebody that I've had sex with it's
working that's not bad to me what's big
number one mistake number one eight
number one man always keep someone in
there that you have slipped your penis
in so at least give you free Red Bull
from your need
there's nothing else the [ __ ] you just
in the strip club with your own money
that you worked hard for giving it to
[ __ ] women who just went to dr and
came back looking a certain way yeah no
no no no no no I'm messing it all up no
yeah but you have to at least get a free
Red Boy out of this deal
how much time would you spend in there
what's what's the good amount of time to
statement I wouldn't stay in there very
long I go in there early I'm ordering my
food I'm ordering my hookah I'm tipping
my waitress I'm leaving I'm gonna go get
a chocolate cake and some [ __ ] milk
and I'm gonna sit there and write a
rhyme miss triplet food is great it is
good it's better than people give it
credit for 100% 100%
speaking of 100% okay so thank you so
dramatic for the cameras guys pretty
good oh how I get it done
whoa
stump [ __ ] a deer bed ah it gets like oh
oh shut up it gets like that this guy's
great
and move on you have a very interesting
line in that you talked about how you
basically have to do your own interviews
because everybody and hip hop media more
or less asks you the same [ __ ] and since
there's a lot of people in hip-hop media
that maybe want to tell you how to rap
or tell you how to act I wonder if you
have any feedback the other way I wonder
if you have any criticisms of rap media
that's a pretty good question I know I
think all of you guys pretty much do a
phenomenal job I'm not sure I believe
you I think you guys represent the
culture I think you guys help to move it
forward and I haven't seen anything ever
reported false or inaccurate with any of
you guys it sounds patronizing when you
say that Joe a little bit I saw you
tweet the other day this is much better
than whatever I read on complex earlier
today I wonder if I wrote some real
folks you today my friend
angel wrote it angel Diaz did you look
at the byline do you ever look at it I
don't ever care about who writes it why
luck
writing it represents the name at the
[ __ ] so I don't care but I don't care
about who wrote it what I'm gonna go
looking for Angel D is way behind while
I could bring over here oh no no no no
no no no meanwhile they offer it a bit
different security ready I'm not cursing
complex out I'm not slamming the phone
or angel Diaz no but it was some it was
very one-sided whatever I read how you
feeling right now fine I'm fine more
almond milk okay who's got the almond
milk good regular or give me the regular
no I don't want anything with silk
written would I do it you guys on your
tricks
I'm trying to [ __ ] me make me me out
here get this silky stuff at the balm
beyond insanity hot sauce don't tell me
any more than that okay because it kind
of speaks for itself so your beard has
inspired more writing than most rappers
whole careers there's all these stories
about a Velcro there's all these stories
about being painted on there are stories
that it's photoshopped it's so
incredible what are your beard tips for
maintaining a good beard because
sometimes I can grow out like a little
bit of a stubble but I can't really get
it going for me is just beard butter and
a good line of beard butter and a good
lineup
well that formula is working great can I
show you five of the most iconic rap
beards and maybe you can tell me
whatever you like and rank them or
whatever one hundred percent let's do it
laptop please I feel like we should get
a drum roll every time that comes
how come here I got the two black guys
just moving a laptop instead of getting
like my milk and [ __ ] I donno yeah well
we're gonna talk to no I Rick Rubin Rick
Rubin Oh classic iconic legendary come
on tec-9 it's got kind of like the fool
man into the beard I don't count that as
a beard and tech can't really have a
beard because he does face paint any
tours for 389 days out of the year
some you don't think that qualifies as a
beer with its as a goatee what do you
think is go t descent but we're talking
beards here a lot more beers bro Phil
yeah another time is measured by the
second have time it [ __ ] judge Rick
Ross Cochise mmm
relax character fair action another
thing the only white people could pull
off where you just look like [ __ ] and
you look great no grooming to you you
just woke up my foot your dog [ __ ]
plating your [ __ ] you [ __ ] you did
Matt [ __ ] and you walk out down and
you look amazing
that's not something that black people
can really do and one more Joe button I
don't like this beer why not that's a
horrible horrible beer cuz my barber
with his [ __ ] head that day really what
did he [ __ ] up I could see it on damn
sure ain't gonna say it earlier but it's
not one of my favorite beers actively
ranked um we got on one first of all the
buzz sorry sorry Ross who's number two
sorry uh uh uh ribbon uh nah can't be
one recruiters good Kevin who's number
two me who's number three techno and we
eliminated we eliminated doesn't qualify
I have to put action Nicks
because action is family that leaves
that number for rick ross today
Mad Dog 357 357 thousand Scoville units
it is a very very hot hot sauce it gets
hotter mentally if you want to start
talking about
how many [ __ ] units of temperature
and CC's in [ __ ] I don't need to hear
all that are you I don't want to hear
any I want to just go okay this one is
the hottest one that took out everyone
from shark tank
this took out Sandra Bullock I got it
all right pull up oh [ __ ]
holy set up that way Oh cute cool y'all
thank you how goes in a little sweet and
then catches you but when things used to
bubble over and wrap there used to be
about it used to be about bar Thank You
Jerry shank cozy shame good subject but
it go one I think this one's made in
Highlands New Jersey by the way open it
up lyrics it used to be about cosines it
used to be about the occasional face to
face you have to enunciate your words
okay when things used to bubble over
wrap the kitchen because that
temperature is just sitting on your
tongue and now I make my lips more
active but you're not helping yourself
either I'm not in that much pain I
respect it I love it this is what I live
for this is why I get out of bed in the
morning Joe to go face-to-face and hot
sauce is against another legend your
room all right when things used to boil
over in hip hop it would be about the
lyrics and it would be about the cosines
it'll be about the occasional face to
face now you kind of need to understand
the internet need to have like a
multimedia 360-degree strategy when it
goes to the go-go's [ __ ] epic
marketing - how do you think an artist
like Eminem another great punchline
artist from that era would fare these
days
do you think that they could be that
they could keep up good question
alright let's see MC would always be
10 years from now when I don't know how
music sounds same way I didn't know how
my phone would operate 10 years ago the
MCS will still be able to emcee this
game was founded on AMC's I don't know
that some of that other [ __ ] will still
be acceptable in 10 years in any in any
setting beef music anywhere you want to
put a cape a capable emcee and emcees
your name your name in top-tier some of
the greatest to ever do it I'm gonna
always bet on them they'll be fine I'm
drinking his milk like it's straight
from a titty god damn it
it is tradition around here to dab the
last wing so that's what I'm gonna do
good thing I'm not from around here you
don't have to if you don't want to Joe
but I'm gonna do it yeah you're way
realer than me okay
little you did all that presentation you
put that bum ass little drop when I read
the last [ __ ] P you okay I don't I
don't see any drop on yours and you're
not putting any I'm not putting I have
no business getting it this is your
[ __ ] show it's not mine I'm not
trying to prove something spread it or
something you put you could easily avoid
that one spot don't use smoke and
mirrors you gave us the whole
presentation and put that little [ __ ]
Drive into this camera and very clearly
um take a bite out of this well I want
to see that one drop I'll pop flower
drops Joe
no just gotten something really [ __ ]
on this guy challenged me to a [ __ ]
hot sauce drool this is some real [ __ ]
wow I'm tougher than they're acceptable
acceptable and I'm a man of my word what
I say two more drops I better switch to
now when I started talking all the [ __ ]
I didn't picture both of us this far in
the game maybe isn't possibly didn't
play all it is out for my vegetable and
then what he said then what really
ticked me off
hahahaha what's his eyes what's uh
what's his method of operation when he
dmg was he Instagram diiemma a Twitter
DM er
I don't know I'm only focused on me and
a Rabb okay Joe see how I dodged it out
I know I see how your dodge [ __ ]
alright we ready for this [ __ ] here we
go oh no I'm doing that too you are
whatever you just did I don't know if
it's a good idea to do that yeah
whatever
I'm still I still got my finger okay
good you got that oh we gotta lure to
agile alright so not gonna talk
oh [ __ ] not good go wow so with this
whole Drake thing become a national
story right with everything everybody
from worldstar to ABC News going
floor-to-ceiling with it I know that
you're somebody who has your fingers on
the pulse when you read about these
stories and hear about these stories
what are people getting wrong I didn't
hear one thing you just say let's give
it two seconds leapin [ __ ] X machine
or some man I need a second it's no joke
I just noticed your nice eyes yeah
that's how I know that [ __ ] was way too
hot if I can't even think or hear
anything I'm just looking at your eyes
or nose yours is in mine 100% I was born
with um [ __ ] white guys and nice eyes
police don't shoot it was great yeah
it's not so bad what do people get wrong
about this story the people think I care
I don't I don't care I don't care about
this I know that's the difference
between me and make you cared I don't I
wish him nothing but the greatest I wish
meek nothing but the greatest I want
everybody to succeed just rap well when
you do it and mention me anyway Joe you
made it through you had fun I did the
floor is yours
this camera or that camera let the
people know what you got going on to you
no no
deuces Joey you just did it for the
sport you don't have anything to promote
I'll call you home
Oh Chuck yes
I'm realistic